Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Aluhut aufgesetzt.
Ich habe mir einen zweiten geholt.
Aluhut ist immer gut. Äh hier ist Lokbuch Netzpolitik einundsiebzigste Ausgabe. Heute ein wenig ähm,
Unser Rot und äh ein bisschen äh unter Zeitdruck. Stimmt's Linus? Du bist in der Diaspora und versuchst dich den äh Entitäten zu entziehen.
So sieht's aus.
Das ist gut. Äh auch in der Diaspora ist unser äh Gast. Wir begrüßen Thomas, Loninger, hallo.
Hallo.
In Wien bisse, ne.
Liebe Grüße? Nein, äh in Portugal.
Ach in Portugal, ne, ist ja super, ist ja eine richtig internationale Sendung heute. Ähm.
Ja, schön über die über die internationalen Grenzen, wo die irgendwo dann immer die Abhörstationen sind, äh damit der Podcast auch vor vorher bei den bei den jeweiligen Entitäten ankommt.
Portugal scheint sehr beliebt zu sein mit äh äh dem Mark, mache ich ja News of the World, auch jetzt derzeit immer aus Portugal,
scheint sozusagen ein neuer Podcast Cluster herauszubilden. Lass uns äh schnell zu äh den Themen kommen
denn die Zeit ist heute ein wenig begrenzter. Ähm tja äh haben wir was verpasst? Also
Mister Snowden
sorgt auch weiterhin für viel heiße Luft und ähm sorgt auch weiterhin für Veröffentlichung besonderer Art,
man kommt schon fast gar nicht mal hinterher. Und man weiß auch noch nicht mal, wo er ist. Es ist alles sehr mysteriös.
Na, er scheint ja anscheinend immer noch in in Moskau zu sein und äh jetzt gerade kam äh die Meldung rein, dass er da irgendwie sich mit Menschenrechtlern, von Amnesty International treffen möchte oder so.
Äh weil er ja verfolgt wird. Ähm vielleicht
müssen wir den den unserer Pflicht äh dadurch äh genügend tun, dass wir sagen, wir befinden uns jetzt in der Woche, in der der Spiegel ähm mit Snowden titelte,
Die stecken mit den NSA unter einer Decke, ja? Das war ein Spiegeltitel Blatt, was man diese Woche sah und da gab's.
Also die Deutschen stecken mit.
Deutschen stecken mit den NS, mit den NSA und Teilen oder mit dem NSA unter einer Decke, also BND und so,
Ähm und diese Sache, diese Aussage, dass der BND eng kooperiert mit der NSA, wurde ja dann sogar von Gerhard Spindler, dem äh Chef da vom BND äh bestätigt.
Das ist also jetzt so ungefähr der Stand. Wir sind auch in der gleichen Woche, in der oder kurz davor, irgendwie der Bundespräsident sagt, na ja, die die NSA speichert das ja nicht in Aktenschränken.
Und ähm also Gauck, ne, wissen wir ja, unser Bundespräsident, der hat ja damals die ähm wenn ich mich jetzt nicht ganz täusche, ich war da ja noch sehr jung, ich bin ja sehr jung, ähm,
doch die Gauckbehörde da äh gehabt oder so.
Hieß die ja auch so. Also eigentlich hieß war's, ich weiß
genau, was der offizielle Titel war, aber es war halt die äh Behörde, die eingerichtet wurde, äh zur Aufarbeitung der Stasi Machenschaften,
und da war er halt der erste Chef von und dann wurde das immer nach seinem nach ihm benannt und hieß Gauck Behörde später, als es dann Marianne Bürtler übergeben hat, wo das dann die Birtlerbehörde, dann spreche natürlich,
ne? Ähm ja, das äh äh ist ja sozusagen auch immer so ein Verdienst, der ihm so zugeschrieben wird, aber man gewinnt zunehmend im Maße den Eindruck, dass der Herr dann doch äh den einen oder anderen Schuss so nicht gehört hat. Auf jeden Fall konnte er so äh jetzt an der neuerlichen
Überwachung so gar nichts finden, weil was wollt ihr eigentlich? Das könnte man ja nicht.
Gibt ja kein, gibt ja gar keine Aktenschränke. Schön war dann, dass,
ich glaub das ging los in der Meldung die die Andretz Politik schaltete hat Andre dann schon mal so gerechnet.
Was jetzt dieser gesamte Stasi-Kram ja an wenn man das in DIN A4 diese die Anzahl der Aktenordner die bei der Stasi angefallen sind in DIN A vier Seiten umrechnen und dann glaube ich mal davon ausgeht dass das nur Text ist,
dann kommt man bei der Datenmenge, die die Stasi angehäuft hat auf zwei Komma acht TB ungefähr, also
handelsüblichen Festplatten, die man sich heute so kauft, also ich zumindest. Drei Terabyte Platte
Da kann ich die gesamte äh angehäufte Information der Stasi drauf speichern.
Während ähm in Utah dieses Rechenzentrum der NSA ähm.
Speicherkapazität hat, die sich in der mir bis dahin äh nicht bekannten äh Größe JA-Bikes berechnet.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie viele Potenzen äh zwischen Jutta Beid und äh Terabyte liegen. Aber wer das mal visualisiert haben möchte, für den hat äh Michael Krall das mal gemacht und hat gesagt, okay wir übernehmen die NSA-Daten.
Rechnen das in DIN A4-Seiten um, rechnen die DIN A4-Seiten in ähm in Akten äh Ordner um, äh rechnen die Aktenordner in Regale um und meinen dann die Fläche auf Google Maps,
die dieses äh dieses diese Reihe von Regalen hätte. Ja und daneben malen wir die zwei Komma acht TB von von der Stasi,
Also einfach mal so, wenn die, wenn beide Entitäten alles ausdrucken. Und äh das kann man sich da sehr schön anschauen. Man muss äh so viel sei verraten,
Es fängt an mit der Stasi und wenn man dann das von der NSA sehen möchte, muss man noch ein bisschen rauscrollen.
Ein bisschen ist gut. Also der Stasibereich lässt sich äh noch bequem so im Regierungsbezirk äh Berlin Mitte
äh unterbringen, während der Aktenschranke der NSA, wenn man das äh Bild dann halt mal bemühen möchte, äh sich dann, glaube ich, so im wesentlichen in einem großen Quadrat von hier bis Dubai äh,
einschließlich des Mittelmeers und all diesem ganzen Kram äh erstrecken würde. Aber dazu muss man auch äh sagen, ich glaube, dass der Anteil von Katzenvideos in der Stasi-Datensammlung doch sehr überschaubar war.
Will's nicht ausschließen, dass da auch welche dabei waren, aber es ist vermutlich recht überschaubar.
Was äh auch aus der Open Data City Ecke kommt ähm
ich glaube, der war so der äh Lorenz Mazert eher äh federführend. Die haben einfach mal so übliche Webseiten getracet,
und haben dann äh so eine schöne Visualisierung gemacht. Welchen Weg geht mein geht die Kommunikation zwischen mir und zum Beispiel Bild DE.
Ja
Und von welchen Geheimdiensten es auszugehen, dass sie dazwischen hängen. Einfach nur mal um das ähm um das ein bisschen zu verdeutlichen, da die Zusammenhänge.
Auch sehr schön, das kann man dann mal gut zeigen. Äh für jeden, dem dem auch so ein bisschen Architektur oder Zusammensetzung des Internets mal ähm.
Mal auch nähergebracht.
Möchte er.
Ja, ist alles ein bisschen äh es ist alles schon wieder so schlimm, dass bei dem Ganzen wirklich nur noch mit so einem Datenzynismus äh entgegentreten kann. Das ist äh immerhin noch konstruktiver als die allgemeine Hilflosigkeit, die sich wohl äh derzeit so in der Politik breit macht,
Man hat so den Eindruck, dass das Thema irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob die in so einer Schockstarre sind
oder und was und wenn ja, was diese Schockstarre eigentlich auslöst, weil man gewinnt den zunehmenden Maße das Gefühl, das ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt
auf einmal schockierend vor Neuigkeiten stehen, sondern eher schockierend vor ähm ja, einer Dokumentation eines Ist-Zustandes,
denen so recht noch keiner zuzugeben bereit ist. Also gerade diese.
Ähm
Äh ich glaube auch gerade, dass die die dieses starke Verwenden von externen Datenvisualisierungen ähm dass dass wir überhaupt jetzt wieder City brauchen, um irgendwie zu begreifen
welche Mengen es dabei geht, das zeigt schon, dass der klassische Journalismus gar nicht mehr in der Lage ist, das zu fassen, welche Dimensionen das hat. Und ich glaube, so geht's der Politik auch.
Ja, also das.
Die die Menge alleine macht's natürlich nicht aus, ne? Und die Suche nach äh Stecknadeln wird nicht dadurch besser, dass man mehr Heu hat
aber es das eigentliche Problem ist, man weiß eigentlich gar nicht, was jetzt wirklich
ähm dazu führt, dass Leute das auch wirklich kritisch sehen, außer unserer üblichen verdächtigen Intelligenz, die ja, die da schon immer kritisch gesehen hat.
Na ja, du wirst die, du wirst ja jetzt nicht die Leute über äh oder man wird nur einen kleinen Teil der Leute überzeugen können, äh,
dass das irgendwie ein Problem ist ähm
wenn sie es nicht bis jetzt begriffen haben, ja. Ich meine, so lange ähm diese dämlichen Argumente kommen, ja, dass alles zu unserem Schutz und wir werden alles schon längst zehnmal von von
terroristischen Islamisten gebraten worden, solange dieses Argument nicht einfach mal dann vernünftig widerlegt wird, ähm.
Wird dieser ja wirst du wird es halt so bleiben, dass Menschen, die nicht auf Anhieb davon darüber empört sind. Wie hast du das im Zweifelsfall auch nicht innerhalb von äh,
mehreren Wochen dann noch erklären können, ja? Dass sie sich dann endlich irgendwann mal bitte empören sollen. Ähm ich finde,
was du gerade angesprochen hast, was mich mich wirklich viel mehr besorgt, ist so diese diese dumm, stumpf, hilflose Lahme äh,
Scheißreaktion aller deutschen Politiker, ja. Ich meine, der Friedrich sagt jetzt, nachdem er, nachdem er sich erst mal eine Woche über anti-amerikanismus beschwert hat, ähm sagt er, sagt er jetzt, er fliegt da jetzt mal hin, ja.
Der Obama hat aber leider natürlich keine Zeit für den.
Also Friedrich kann er dahinfliegen, kann sich mit irgendwelchen, mit der Reihe drei da mal unterhalten, die werden ihm sagen, Kollege,
halt die Fresse. So und dann wird der nach Hause fahren und sagen, ja wir haben eine tolle Freundschaft.
Ähm unsere Bundeskanzlerin stellt sich hin und sagt, äh dass Nachrichtendienste unter bestimmten und in unserem Land eng gefassten rechtlichen Voraussetzungen zusammenarbeiten, entspricht ihren Aufgaben seit Jahrzehnten und dient unserer Sicherheit. Ja klar, also das,
Ich meine, das musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Das ist äh also die gibt da, die gibt doch da vollständig auf, ja. Da würde ich da würde ich mir, da habe ich aber größte Sympathie für jeden äh süd- oder lateinamerikanischen Regierungschef, der da wenigstens mal den Mund aufmacht.
Also ich bin da sehr, sehr ähm sehr, sehr enttäuscht und du kannst es ja ähm,
Kannst es ja dann noch ähm sehen. Da kommen ja dann so so nebenbei liegst, ja, die dann schon gar nicht mehr irgendwie auf der auf der auf der Titelseite sind. Wie das der United States postet Service da irgendwie ein Programm hat, wo sie irgendwie allein,
einem Jahr sind zweitausendzwölf hundertsechzig Milliarden Sendungen.
Äh immer das das Absender und Empfängerfeld fotografiert und gespeichert haben. Jetzt müssen wir dazu sagen, so eine Technik haben die natürlich, weil sie diese hundertsechzig Milliarden Sendung eben ab
äh lief ähm hier,
abwickeln müssen und die haben natürlich verfügen die über enorm äh gute ähm Handschrifterkennungsprogramme, ne, macht die Deutsche Post genauso. Da sitzen heute nicht mehr Menschen, die einzeln gucken, wo sie den Brief jetzt hintragen.
Das heißt, wenn sie diese hundertsechzig Milliarden Dinger da speichern, haben sie natürlich auch eine Schrifterkennung, weil sonst hätten sie einfach nur eine große Festplatte voll mit Fotos, mit der sie nichts anfangen können.
Anfrage geben sie das dann an Behörden raus. Das ist jetzt, wie gesagt, alles noch USA.
Auf Anfrage geben sie das an Behörden raus, ohne richterliche Kontrolle, also genau wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Deutschland gedacht ist. Und davon haben die einfach mal fünfzehn bis zwanzigtausend Vorgänge im Jahr,
Das heißt, der komplette äh komplette Postverkehr unterliegt dann da.
Da liegt er in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Deutsche Post sagt dann, ja, wir schicken auch Daten an an US-Behörden.
Weil wir damit die Zollabfertigung erleichtern, was das denn für ein Quatsch?
Und das wird einfach so, das ist ganz normaler Tag, ja. Äh ganz normale Meldung äh in, in der heutigen, in der heutigen Welt, in der wir leben. Gleichzeitig setzt sagt dann die EU
Ja, jetzt machen wir aber mal hier,
parlamentarische Untersuchungskommission, ne? Weil immerhin wurden ja anscheinend unsere Telefonanlagen abgehört und die Gebäude, in denen wir uns treffen, verwandst,
und der komplette Datenverkehr geht irgendwie, wird irgendwie der von uns in die USA geht, den schnappen sich die Briten und die Amis.
Da machen wir mal eine parlamentarische Untersuchungskommission. Jetzt wollen wir mal gucken. Und dann gehen die einen hin und sagen, wir wollen direkt mal den den NSA-General einladen, den NSA-General einladen.
Und dann kommen die kommen UK und Schweden und sagen, ja ähm,
Da wollen wir ja jetzt mal hier gar nicht so das große geheimdienstliche Fass aufmachen. Ich würde sagen, wir fokussieren uns mal,
auf den Datenschutz, denn so muss ja hier jeder im Raum wissen, Angelegenheiten der nationalen Sicherheit sowie Geheimdienstarbeit liegen nicht in der Zuständigkeit der EU.
Also was äh was für Flachpfeifen sitzen denn da? Also ich bin wirklich völlig entgeistert. Und das kann ja nicht daran liegen, dass sie alle äh völlig blöd sind, sondern da muss ja einfach ähm also ja gut, entweder doch kann natürlich.
Also ich finde, ja, ich finde, es wird jetzt langsamer Zeit für ein paar steile Thesen so, ja? Ähm wenn sich sozusagen hier, wenn alle überwacht werden und wenn auch die gesamte privat Kommunikation mitgeschnitten wird,
Und wenn jetzt nach Bekanntwerden dieses Ganzen kein Politiker,
nennenswerter Position sich hier erhebt und mal klar Stellung bezieht zu einem Vorgang, der ganz offensichtlich gegen unsere Verfassung verstößt, nämlich Schutz des,
äh das äh ähm wie heißt das, des der Telekommunikation, das Postgeheimnis. Ich weiß nicht, wie ist denn das jetzt aktuell formuliert.
Und so weiter.
Was,
So, dann kann man ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass vermutlich von diesen Geheimdiensten auf diese Politiker Druck ausgeübt wird, wo sie mit ihrer privaten Kommunikation erpresst werden.
Allesamt. Das heißt, die Frage ist,
Was haben sie denn eigentlich alles da grade zu verderben? Werken das jetzt Maul nicht aufmachen? Die einzige Erklärung für ihre Argumentation kann doch nur sein,
Dass er schon längst irgendwie äh eine Batterie Schlapphüte äh hinter ihnen steht und sagt, wenn du das Maul aufmachst, dann Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Glaube ich eine ganz interessante Diskussionsbasis, so wo man dann mal so ja,
auch schwierig drauf antworten kann, aber äh das möchte ich ja jetzt gerne erst mal widerlegt sehen. Weil was, was ist denn bitte der andere Grund, sonst, dass sie äh sich so verhalten?
Ich,
äh ich glaube, also ich ich würde auch sagen, es muss irgendwo muss eine riesige Druckkulisse sein. Wir haben ja schon in der letzten Sendung auch die ähm die Forsche Potsachen äh benannt. Ähm
also die die Forschung oder die Ergebnisse zu den der Historiker da gekommen ist äh über die Geheimabkommen zwischen äh USA und zumindest Deutschland ähm.
Ich denke, die Geheimdienste haben einfach so eine lange Tradition, aber es muss auch, also es muss auch den anderen Aspekt geben, jetzt nochmal.
Also ich glaube, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es nur der Faktor ist, dass die Geheimdienste, die Leute erpressen oder so, ne. Ähm ich denke.
Das will ich damit auch nicht sagen, aber das das ist, sagen wir mal, etwas, was die, ich sage nur, das könnte diese Diskussion mal etwas beleben.
Ja dir klar, die Frage muss man sich auf jeden Fall mal stellen. Also.
Die muss man denen mal stellen und äh auch bei Herrn Friedrich, also der macht ja auch so den Eindruck, als dürfte er irgendwas nicht sagen. Oder wollte er irgendwas.
Ich glaube, also der Friedrich, der, der, der, der ist Innenminister, der will auch sowas nicht sagen. Der, also der, der steht ja nochmal aufm ganz, der steht für mich irgendwie sowieso nochmal auf so einem ganz anderen Blatt. Also, der Typ ähm das nochmal eine Sache, ne. Ich meine.
Also nochmal kurz zu dieser, zu dieser parlamentarischen Untersuchungskommission zurück. Ja, Cecilia Maimström sagt dann, sie wird aber jetzt ähm.
Auf jeden Fall mal in die USA fliegen und wird sich wird sich bestätigen lassen.
Dass die Abkommen über die Flug äh Gastdaten äh äh Austausch
und über die äh Finanzdaten, also dieses Swift äh Geschichte da, dass das schon datenschutzrechtlich alles in Ordnung ist. Das möchte sie sich versichern lassen. Das heißt, sie fährt schon mit dem Wunsch, mit dem,
Wunsch hin liebe USA.
Überzeugt mich bitte kurz, dass das alles in Ordnung ist. Die geht nicht dahin und sagt, das ganze Ding steht auf der Kippe und wenn ich da nicht sofort was höre, fließt er ab morgen, fließen ab morgen keine Daten mehr hin, sondern die sagt, ich fliege da jetzt mal hin, dann trinken wir einen netten Kaffee,
Und dann sagt er mir, sagt er mir bitte sichert ihr mir bitte mündlich zu, dass das alles in Ordnung ist? Und dann fliege ich wieder nach Hause.
Gleichzeitig wird dann also.
Fand ich dann noch die Schärfe. Also da da weißt du dann auch, dass die vollständig alle den alle den Zusammenhang verloren. Äh den den Verstand verloren haben. Diskutieren sie dann und sagen, na ja.
Was ja übrigens auch mal ganz gut wäre, wo man ja mal drüber nachdenken könnt, diese parlamentarische Untersuchungskommission, ja? Im Rahmen dieser Debatte steht dann einer auf und sagt, na ja, wir könnten doch mal einen EU-Geheimdiensten machen,
parlamentarischer Kontrolle, weil dat ja so gut klappt, weil wir ja hier sehen, dass das so eine gute Idee ist.
Also wie wie völlig bescheuert sind die denn? Da fällt mir nichts mehr zu ein. Sorry, da also.
Parlamentarische Kontrolle für einen Geheimdienst, weißt du? Und und bei einer Geheimdienst-Affäre, die irgendwie die gesamte Welt erschüttert, also.
Ja.
Wo die wo,
also das, das ist auf so vielen Ebenen falsch, da müssen wir jetzt eine Sendung füllen, um die ganzen Widersprüche in diese in dieser Idee überhaupt äh wiederzuspiegeln. Und na ja, dann äh,
Verhandlung hier, dieses da hatten wir ja schon diesen, äh, mir fällt der Name gerade nicht ein, diesen Politikberater, den US Politikberater, der in der Anne Will-Sendung war letzte Woche, in der ja auch Konstanze kurz war,
irgendwie direkt zur Beginnung der zu Beginn der Sendung sagte, na ja, das wäre aber doch schade,
wenn jetzt da dieses Freihandelsabkommen nicht zustande kommt, verzögert wird deswegen, da können Deutschland ja viele Millionen Euro verloren gehen,
Und genau das äh Argument hat dann auch gezogen,
irgendeine Verzögerung, die angedrohte, eventuelle Verzögerung in den US-amerikanischen Verhandlungen, äh den EU
EU-US Verhandlungen, die ja so schon das das Schlimmste war, was da angekündigt wurde, der könnte sich verzögern. Ähm selbst das haben sie nicht gemacht. Also es,
Naja, da muss, wie gesagt, du hast schon Recht, stimmt. Da da müssen einfach nochmal ganz andere Sachen hinterhängen, dass da, dass da keiner aufsteht und den den Arsch in der Hose hat,
gerade zumindest vor Opposition wäre das ja jetzt wirklich der, der entscheidende Punkt, aber die reizen ja auch nicht wirklich den Mund auf.
Ähm was ich,
nochmal Thomas fragen wollte, was hier so ein bisschen wenig zur Sprache gekommen ist. Äh es gab doch jetzt letzte Woche diesen äh Fall mit evomoralis, der da heruntergewunken wurde und die äh
Durchsuchung seines äh Flugzeuges, was ja in Südamerika zu einem riesen,
So eine riesen Aufregung gefüttert, verständlicherweise. Wie ist denn das in Österreich reflektiert worden, dass das so in Österreich durchgeführt wurde?
Man hat sich ein bisschen gefreut, dass Wien mal wieder im Zentrum der internationalen Medienöffentlichkeit.
Wir sind wieder wer.
Wir waren ja früher schon Dreh- und Angelscheibe von Geheimdiensten äh im Kalten Krieg. Ist ein neutrales Land. Ähm das.
Ah, die ist wieder der dritte Mann und so.
Ja genau
und ein paar bekannte Journalistinnen sind dann mitten in der Nacht zum Flughafen geflogen gefahren und haben dort irgendwie versucht paranoid aussehenden Nerds mit Laptop in einer Ecke zu finden, also,
schauen, ob's Noten wirklich dort ist, war natürlich nicht
Die interessanteste Analyse zu dieser ganzen Sache kam eigentlich von einem von ehemaligen Chef unseres Geheimdienstes
gemeint hat, dass es eigentlich der größte Eklat für die amerikanische Außenpolitik, den es seit langem gegeben hat, weil ihr es nicht offensichtlich wurde, dass äh die USA hier in mehreren europäischen Ländern interveniert haben,
und äh dass er vermutet, dass Russland dahinter eigentlich mit diesem kontrollierten Rauslassen äh das angeblich des Norden im Flugzeug von Morales sitzt, äh einfach bloß gestellt hat, wie stark die amerikanische Kontrolle auf,
souveräne europäische Staaten heutzutage eigentlich ist.
Das ist krass. Ja, ich meine, wenn du wenn das wirklich stimmt, dann haben die Russen da wirklich einen geilen Hack hingelegt.
Also das das ist keine schlechte Theorie.
Ja ja, also das da äh ich kann mir sowieso vorstellen, dass sie gerade echt eine Menge Spaß haben da in Russland. Also ich glaube, die haben echt eine gute Zeit.
Na ja, wobei ja nochmal, also ähm es ist ja noch nicht mal ein Geheimnis, die USA sagen ja selber, also äh.
Die USA sagen ja selber, dass sie jedem Land, dass äh ein Asylantrag von Snowden bekommen hat oder ähm.
Überflugsrechte gewähren könnte, wenn Snowden in einem entsprechenden Land äh in ein entsprechendes Land müsste. Das heißt, eigentlich jedem Land
ja. Also ich glaube, es gibt wenige Länder auf der Erde, die weder einen Asylantrag von Snowden haben, noch noch noch
die Gefahr laufen Überflugrechte gewähren zu müssen oder verwehren zu können, wenn der in eines der vielen Länderpflicht in die ein Asylantrag gestellt hat, jedes einzelne Land
kriegt gerade von USA einen eingeschenkt und den wird gesagt, was denn so die Konsequenzen sind, die diplomatischen, wenn.
Wenn sie zum Beispiel das Asyl oder diese Überflugsrechte gewähren würden. Und da bin ich schon echt äh.
Da bin ich schon, also da bin ich nun bin ich nicht wirklich verwundert. Ich finde das aber auch ehrlich gesagt sehr überraschend.
Dass die USA das sogar selber zugeben, dass die sagen, jedes Land, was irgendwo da jetzt hier irgendwas machen könnte, was uns nicht gefällt, den erklären wir jetzt schon mal ähm.
Genau, erklären wir jetzt schon mal, was wir dann machen. So, den die oder was heißt, hm, wahrscheinlich erklären sie's doch nicht mal. Da da sitzt wahrscheinlich auch ein Politikberater im Fernsehen und sagt.
Ja, also schön, schön, schön, schönes Land haben Sie da, wäre doch schade, wenn dem was zustoßen würde.
Wäre doch schade, wenn wenn sie hier auf einmal keinen Export mehr hätten, ne, oder oder kein Import, ja, also ähm.
Und was die noch alles führen. Natürlich sind die Verstrickungen mit so einer, mit mit so einem Land äh enorm, also an,
Die USA haben die Macht ja nicht, äh weil sie ein großes Land sind. Äh und ein großes Militär haben. Sie haben die Macht natürlich auch aufgrund der der Verstrickung, die sie mit jedem einzelnen Land haben und der Abhängigkeiten,
ähm die andere Länder eben gegenüber den USA haben. Und da.
Also das ist jetzt echt so super, Obama. Ich meine, ich habe eh nicht damit gerechnet, dass der Guantanamo Bait zumachen würde. Ich habe immer gesagt, äh wenn der US-Präsident ist, dann ist er US-Präsident und US-Präsident werden nur Leute, die US-Präsident,
sein können und der wird halt US-Präsident sein und da wird keine großartige Änderung passieren. Ähm aber,
aber das, was, was ich da jetzt irgendwie sehe, das würde mich sogar bei Busch noch äh bei Busch würde ich noch sagen, jetzt ist noch eine noch ein eine neue Facette seiner tiefen schwarzen Seele ausgeleuchtet worden, die mir noch nicht bekannt war. Also sowas von,
Also dieses Verhalten unglaublich, wirklich fällt mir, fällt mir wenig zu ein. Selbst bei Busch hätte ich so, bitte.
Du redest von Obama gerade.
Nein, nein, ich ich rede von Obama und sage aber selbst bei Bush hätte mich das noch
hätte ich das noch noch so ein bei Busch wäre das sogar noch immer noch was gewesen, wo ich gesagt hätte, das ist was Neues, ja? Das ist eine neue Qualität. Und von dem hat man eigentlich sowieso schon alles erwartet. Bin ja froh, dass der die Welt nicht in Schutt und Asche gelegt hat, sondern nur Teile davon.
Ähm gut, kommen wir zurück. Snowden, ähm.
Hat ja ähm mehrmals schon den Wink aus Venezuela bekommen, dass man äh einen Asylantrag von ihm äh sehr wohlwollend gegenüberstehen würde.
Ja, die würden sich gerne die Plakette Number one äh anheften, die die Amerikaner gerade ausgelobt haben.
Wollen die halt haben. Ist doch okay. Ich meine, irgendeiner muss das ja machen.
Ich habe da ähm.
Interessanterweise, also und und Snowden hat ihn jetzt auch äh gestellt, diesen Antrag. Das heißt, so jetzt müsste er ihn wieder rüber. Ähm.
Ich fand da eine sehr sehr schöne Artikel, in dem stand, dass hier teilweise in in Venezuela gar nicht unbedingt so.
Also die sind auch relativ stark da äh.
Geheimdienstlich unter Kontrolle und so und unter Überwachung und haben noch nicht mal so um also,
Skandal empfinden, sondern da wurde der Begriff in diesem Zeitungsartikel, wo der Begriff Gringo-Petze,
strapaziert, dass sie also den als ja das ist halt die Petze von den Amis.
Er ist eine Petze, aber ich meine, immerhin von den Amis und deswegen nehmen wir den,
Weißt du so, so wurde das in dem Artikel dargestellt. Ich war noch nie in Venezuela, ähm ich weiß nicht, ob die das tatsächlich so sehen.
Aber ähm auch in dieser Woche äh oder seit der letzten Sendung äh passiert ähm oder hatten wir es in der letzten Sendung schon erzählt, dass Ecuador eine Wanze in der Botschaft gefunden hat in in London?
Glaube ja, oder? Bin jetzt grad.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ecuador, Ecuadorianische Botschaft in London, verwandst ja, Julian Assange rennt da seit einem Jahr drin rum und die haben vor drei Wochen irgendwie schon äh da irgendwie eine Wandzettelin gefunden. Alles echt gut
alles sehr, sehr geschmackvoll alles, was man da so hört. Und dann gab's ja noch diesen schönen, gab's ja noch ein paar Details über diesen,
Fisk, den Foren Intelligence.
Warte mal also diese der die der die Anträge über den zu den.
Abstempelt und wir wussten ja schon, dass dieser äh Fisk ähm eben.
In einem ganzen Jahr nicht einen einzigen Antrag ähm abgelehnt hat, ja. Also diese Richter, das sind elf Personen, ähm muss man sich vorstellen, also ein Gericht, elf Personen und vor diesem Gericht ist aber immer nur eine Person.
Rechtliche Entität dort und das ist halt die Regierung.
Da gibt's also quasi keinen, da gibt's nur einen Antragsteller und keinen, der da der sich dagegen verteidigt oder so, ne?
Also ob jetzt hier Konfusion zu vermeiden, Fisk ist jetzt eine US-amerikanische Institution, weil du bist gerade so von äh Britannien hin und her gesprungen, um das nochmal klarzumachen.
Genau das ist der, das ist der äh das ist der.
Genau, das ist der, das ist das Gericht, das die das sind die Richter, die
der NSA dann die Erlaubnis geben, bestimmte Sachen abzuhören. Und man hatte sich ja schon, man hatte ja schon eben, man wusste ja das ist eine Stempelbude, weil die auf ja offensichtlich keinen einzigen Antrag da jemals abgelehnt haben.
Und,
natürlich und das finde ich auch finde ich auch absolut richtig, das hätte ich an deren Stelle genauso gemacht. Ähm die Richter können ja nicht da jeden, jeden einzelnen Zugriff äh dann da äh,
er genehmigen. Und deswegen haben sie einfach mal zehn Sonder über zehn Sonderurteile gefällt,
Wo sie den Richtervorbehalt abgeschafft haben. Nämlich, wenn's zum Beispiel um Cyberangriffe oder das iranische Atomprogramm geht, dann braucht die NSA
sich da gar nicht mehr bei denen zu melden. Das finde ich auch okay, weil wenn man sich das Ausmaß der Überwachung anschaut, dass die NSA da betreibt, dann wären diese elf äh Richter ja wohl absolut
überlastet, da jetzt jedes Mal noch einen Stempel drunter zu machen, ne, also wo zur Senkung der eigenen.
Rechte, ne, also ich meine Richter dürfen nicht einfach so ausgebeutet werden.
Eben, ne, wenn die da irgendwie, ne, wenn die da langfristig Überstunden machen müssen oder so, dann kann man besser einfach mal einen Freibrief geben.
Und dann äh kann man auch mal Sonntag Nachmittags mit den Kindern spielen gehen und muss da nicht die ganze Zeit noch Überwachungsbefehle.
Denkt doch mal einer an die Kinder.
Es ist echt äh.
Ist schon ein bisschen absurd. Also äh was eigentlich sehr schön ist, ist, dass die,
Das alles, was bisher eigentlich immer so ein bisschen vermutet wurde und unterstellt wurde, jetzt irgendwie total klar ist
irgendwie, also jetzt gibt's da einfach auch wirklich nichts mehr dran äh äh zu rütteln. Es mag sein, dass immer noch keiner zuhören möchte, aber zumindest ist man die Faktenlage klar. Ich bin übrigens äh zufällig ähm so aus der Abteilung To-Io so, äh bin ich auf einen
Chaosradio von vor fünfzehn Jahren hingewiesen worden.
Radio vierunddreißig.
Und äh ich habe dann da mal reingehört und und so nach einer halben Stunde dachte ich, Alter, ich werde nicht wieder, ja, wo dann irgendwie Andy und Frank Rieger irgendwie ausholen.
Und so ziemlich akkurat die Situation von heute beschreiben.
Also wirklich so mit ja in den NSA und hängen dann irgendwie auf allen Kanälen, schneiden alles mit und das ist irgendwie auch alles gar kein Problem und das mit den Daten, das kriegt man schon irgendwie auch hin und so weiter. Also blieb mir echt die Spucke weg.
Nochmal drauf verlinken, aber es ist wirklich so zum, zum Nachhören äh aus der Abteilung. Wir haben's ja schon immer gewusst, äh es ist schon wirklich Hardcore.
Hammer. So sieht's aus.
So sieht's aus. So, haben wir denn jetzt äh die LSA-News soweit zusammengefasst, irgendwas Neues war noch, ne?
Soweit ich das alles ach ja genau ähm also man kommt ja auch kaum noch hinterher. Äh wir hatten's gerade angesprochen. Microsoft.
Genau richtig, das war's noch. Mhm. Das ist jetzt die neueste Nachricht, dass ähm.
Eine von Snowden verteiltes Dokument, offenbar dokumentiert, dass äh Microsoft, dem NSA, da freimütig Zugang
zu äh der Verschlüsselungsinfrastruktur gegeben hat oder entsprechende Kies bereitgestellt hat. Das ist ja auch etwas, was auch Microsoft schon längere Zeit unterstellt wird so
NSA Key war schon immer mal so ein Windows ausgeliefert worden, wo so die äh
variabel, einen variablen Namen, die nicht gestript wurden und dann gab's da irgendwie eine NSA-Key Variable,
die schon immer so ein bisschen äh Fragezeichen erzeugt hat.
Ach das die kam von Apple.
Auf jeden Fall,
sieht es so aus, dass ähm der NSA wohl ziemlich ungeschützten Zugang hat und zwar sehr direkten Zugang hat zu den E-Mail- und sonstigen Messaging, Infrastrukturen, einschließlich Skype,
ja? Bis hin zur äh Videoübertragung, das heißt die Unterstellung an der Stelle ist
Das ist für den NSA überhaupt gar kein Problem, sich im Prinzip in jede beliebige Video, Skype-Konferenz.
Einzuschalten, sprich mit zu lauschen. Äh natürlich auch die ganzen Audiosachen damit und äh vermutlich auch der ganze Textchat. Und dasselbe gilt eben auch für Hot-Mail und für Outlook dot com und
diese ganzen Sachen. Und an der Stelle ähm muss ich auch sagen, dass ich eine,
Sache, bisher nur am Rande. Von manchen geäußert gesehen habe in dieser ganzen Debatte und wo ich mich auch wirklich mal fragen äh würde, inwiefern eigentlich eine konservative CDU, FDP äh Regierung dann,
eigentlich vertreten kann. Mag ja sein, dass diese ganze Überwachung von Privatleuten alles scheiß egal ist. Ja?
Schneidet doch alles mit irgendwie jeder Bürger wird komplett überwacht und wehe uns wenn irgendwann mal wirklich die Nazis hier an die Regierung kommen, dann ist halt schon mal das Instrumentarium im diesen Zustand auch nie wieder erinnern zu können.
So, ja? Gegessen.
Aber äh wie ist es denn mit der Tatsache, dass hier im Prinzip die USA unter dem Wimpel des der Terrorismusbekämpfung einen vollständigen Zugriff hat auf die Kommunikations
Infrastruktur unserer Wirtschaft.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man einfach mal auch den Fokus mal weg äh bringen von diesem ganzen Privatsphäre auf der einen Seite und äh Terror auf der anderen Seite
zu dem, was hier offensichtlich auch eine große äh Rolle spielt, nämlich ähm Wirtschaftspolitik
Hier wird.
Gelauscht auf allen Kanälen. Der gesamte Mittelstand Deutschlands und natürlich auch die großen Konzerne, die sich sicherlich eine Menge auch über ihre Strategien und ihre äh äh sonstigen,
Pläne austauschen, einschließlich der Pläne selbst stehen hier im Prinzip mitten im Fokus. Und das ist ja keine Neuigkeit, dass auch die Geheimdienste äh der USA
ihren Auftrag nicht unbedingt jetzt immer nur zur Gefahrenabwehr sehen, beziehungsweise diese Gefahrenabwehr soweit definieren,
dass diese Gefahr ja auch eben in der wirtschaftlichen Übermacht eines anderen Landes
stehen kann, sprich die Geheimdienste auch, die Aufgabe haben, die äh wirtschaftliche Unfähigkeit äh bestimmter Branchen dadurch vielleicht auszugleichen, ihnen Informationen zu liefern, ähm an die sie so selber gar nicht herangekommen wären.
Das äh ist definitiv so ein Aspekt, der mir in der ganzen Debatte äh fehlt. Sag mal Thomas, wie wird denn das,
In Österreich diskutiert.
Ähm also von von unseren Innenministerinnen her ist es leider eine sehr,
erbärmliche Show, also da hört man hin und wieder auch dieses Betroffenheitsgedusel, aber ähm klare Schritte und harte Worte gab's da eigentlich noch nicht.
Glaube ich auch nicht nur wirklich erwartet. Also dafür ist äh versteht sich Österreich da inzwischen als nicht mehr wichtig genug und ähm es es ist zwar hin und wieder eine Mainstream-Medien, aber wird auch noch nicht zu heiß gekocht, wie wie glaube ich in Deutschland.
Ja, ich glaube, während sich hier die Leute noch drüber aufregen, so zumindest so ein bisschen drüber aufregen, abgehört werden zu äh zu werden
Habe ich so fast den Eindruck, in Österreich würde man sich geradezu darüber freuen, dass man so wichtig genommen wird, dass man's auch verdient hat, abgehört zu werden oder wie?
Na, die Frage ist eher so äh,
außenpolitisch hat Österreich halt einfach nicht das diplomatische Gewicht aus Deutschland hat und wenn, dann bereut's dafür halt eine koordinierte europäische Antwort.
Und es gibt ja ähm wir haben wir haben einen Österreicher, glaube ich, der äh Vize ist vom Europaparlament, wir haben ähm der Chef der Sozialdemokraten im Europaparlament ist. Also da gibt's eigentlich die Leute, die dem Ganzen auch Gewicht geben könnten, aber auf europäischer Ebene,
ja, ich weiß nicht, woran's da scheitert, wahrscheinlich an der Kommission.
Das wäre für mich eher der Weg, wo man auch was erreichen könnte. Weil womit sollen wir drohen?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Dass er äh künftig keine Staatsführer mehr vom Himmel holt auf Anweisungen, so.
Nein, also das ist dafür ist die ähm dieses Geflecht zwischen Österreich und ausländischen Diensten viel zu dicht. Das ist ja in Österreich so
offen für generell so geheimdiensttätigkeiten laut dem österreichischen Gesetz ist jede Art von Geheimdienst Tätigkeit auf österreichischem Boden legal, solange sie nicht zum Nachteil der Republik ist.
Drückt schon sehr gut aus, was so die Denke ist dahinter.
Ich frage mich auch, ob in Österreich auch ähnliches Verhältnis zu den Geheimdiensten äh besteht, was jetzt sozusagen die freiwillig eingeräumten Rechte betrifft, wie das jetzt hier auch äh in Deutschland immer gewesen ist,
eigentlich sozusagen das Abhören des Landes schon immer so ein,
Ja, schön, dass ihr euch jetzt zurückgezogen habt. Ihr dürft dann, ihr dürft dafür dann ein bisschen noch zuhören, damit ihr euch auch sicher fühlt, ob's äh solche Vereinbarungen auch in Österreich.
Wäre mir nichts bekannt.
Ja, aber wenn man.
Das das Thema parlamentarische Kontrolle ist sicherlich ein riesiges und ungelöstes.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie alles ein ähm schwieriges Feld und ähm es macht uns auch alle so ein wenig ratlos. Ratlos,
Macht es äh übrigens auch den äh Enno. Das ist jetzt nochmal so ein Hinweis von uns hier aufm schönen äh Blogpost, auf dem Blog die äh Enomane. Ähm.
Hast du das gesehen hier, Prisum, ein paar lebens äh Lügen. Sehr schön, also ist im Prinzip nochmal so eine Zusammenfassung,
und so ein bisschen so ein Abgesang an so ein paar,
Vorstellungen, die wir bisher äh immer äh so hochgehalten haben, äh teilt das hier so in fünf Lebenslügen auf, Lebenslüge eins,
Rechtstaat Deutschland, ja? Also das ist hier sich wirklich das gilt glaube ich in dem selben Maße dann auch für Österreich. Ja, also das.
Hier wirklich sozusagen das Recht äh regiert, aber das eben einfach so viele Beispiele in den letzten Jahrzehnten
und aber auch in den letzten Jahren, er verweist da auch diese Funkzellenabfrage in Sachsen, die wir hier ausführlich äh diskutiert haben, die Vorfälle und Staatstrojaner et cetera, dass das eigentlich,
sagen wir mal, auch so ein
Bild ist, von dem man sich langsam mal ein bisschen verabschieden sollte, weil das in gewisser Hinsicht auch äh ja, immer alles so ein bisschen beschönigt mit so nach dem Motto, na ja, immerhin leben wir ja noch in einem Rechtsstaat. Das ist ja so diese klassische äh ja äh
Entschuldigung, alle werden erschossen, aber immerhin leben wir ja noch in einem Rechtsstaat. Jetzt übertreibe ich ein bisschen, aber.
Nee, das kann man schon oft.
Also ich meine, die Nazis hatten auch einen Rechtsstaat, die haben nicht illegal gehandelt, also ein ein Rechtsstaat ist zwar eine notwendige, aber keine hinreichende Bedingung für eine freie Demokratie. Wir brauchen immer noch Grundrechte, die eingehalten werden,
und ähm ich will nicht vorgreifen, aber darum ging's ja auch bei dem Verfahren zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung vom Europäischen Gerichtshof, ob diese Grundrechte auf Datenschutz und Schutz der Privatsphäre noch greifen gegenüber solchen Überwachungsmaßnahmen
oder ob das eben nicht der Fall ist. Das ist so die Kernfrage, um die es eigentlich geht.
Ja
Genau, das ist ja auch sein sein dritter Punkt ist hier so sozusagen Lebenslüge Demokratie, also dass eben alles hier äh wirklich vom Volk aus äh gestaltet wird und äh.
Wenn man sich anschaut, wie eben jetzt sozusagen unsere Vertreter äh sich verhalten, ist das dass sie einfach dagegen ja das sozusagen darauf.
Sagen, dass das einfach dieses System der Kontrolle an der Stelle so überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert, beziehungsweise die Leute, die eben die Macht delegiert bekommen haben, daran gar kein Interesse haben, sich daran an diesen Prinzipien zu orientieren, ne. Ja, dann,
Freund Amerika ist sozusagen so eine andere These, ja, also sozusagen auch so dieses, das sind ja alles unsere Freunde und dann dann ist das ja alles nicht so schlimm,
Aber das eben zwischen diesen Nationen.
Ein knallharter Wettbewerb besteht, der also am Ende und das gilt ja eigentlich auch für Deutschland, dass man Deutschland verhält, sich gegenüber anderen Ländern da auch nicht anders und Österreich auch nicht, also alle machen das. Ja, es ist immer so, alle gegen alle,
man tut halt schön freundlich, wenn einem das irgendwie nutzt, aber im Wesentlichen ist es so ein permanenter Krieg, der.
Dort stattfindet, dessen muss man sich halt einfach auch irgendwie,
klar werden, ne? Na ja, dann im Internet gibt es Privatsphäre ist sozusagen auch äh etwas, von dem wir uns, glaube ich, jetzt wirklich verabschieden können und äh auch diese ganze Datenschutz ähm.
Illusionen, ja, ist halt sozusagen.
Über das man mal nachdenken sollte, ob sich das eben so noch aufrecht erhalten lässt als Zustandsbeschreibung. Wir verlinken dadrauf,
die Enomane DE.
Wichtig finde ich auch noch den Punkt, mit dem er endet. Das hat nicht das Internet kaputt ist und auch nicht das Internet an dieser Überwachung Schuld ist. Also auch wenn man jetzt äh jeder Technik entschwört, die Überwachung passiert ja trotzdem. Also man
kann dem Problem nicht mit Technikabstinenz beikommen, sondern,
Man muss sich eben sozusagen auf die Grundwerte kümmern und in dem Sinne ist das Internet nur wieder einmal ein Spiegel unserer Gesellschaft.
Richtig.
So, jetzt müssen wir an dieser Stelle äh leider dem Linus ähm Lebewohl sagen, Linus muss schnell weg. Stimmt's Linus?
So sieht's aus. Ich äh es tut mir leid, ich bedanke mich.
Genau, mach's gut, bis bald.
Bis bald.
So, aber ein Thema äh haben wir noch. Ähm,
Wir müssen uns nochmal ein bisschen hier über äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung unterhalten. Natürlich hat jetzt diese ganze Snowden-Debatte.
Auch die Diskussion um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zumindest so gefühlt so ein wenig nochmal nach oben gespürt die CDU hier eiert auch schon wieder kräftig rum und gab dann auch so eine merkwürdige Meldung,
auf Spiegel Online, die dann irgendwie CDU tritt von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung zurück.
Das äh blieb da nicht lange diese Headline, weil sie sich da doch irgendwie weiß ich nicht, was da schief gelaufen ist, aber sind da im Prinzip nur so einem der CDU in ihrem Wahlprogramm auf den Leim gegangen,
weil sie quasi das Wort Vorratsdatenspeicherung überhaupt nicht mehr erwähnen,
sondern stattdessen jetzt konsequent diesen Friedrich-Sprech äh übernehmen mit äh Mindestspeicherdauer und so. Ja, also der Versuch, dieses leicht verbrannte,
Wort da wegzunehmen. Man merkt auch überhaupt Wahlkampf greift über hier von der SPD wird dann eben auch kräftig,
draufgehauen,
Und das sah ja alles ganz furchtbar und alles ganz schlimm, ja, aber die SPD hat's ja auch selber im Programm stehen und das ist alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. Die CSU versucht auch gerade so den Eindruck zu machen
wasche mich aber mache mich nicht nass. Äh,
da irgendwie auf einmal so die Datenschutzkeule in der Hand habend äh wir waren ja schon immer dagegen. Also das ist alles äh äh merkwürdig und äh verstört und man merkt auch, dass jetzt gerade in der Sommerpause hier eine Menge Leuten.
Ähm so ein bisschen die Argumentation flöten geht, die sie sich äh zurechtgelegt haben und dass sie jetzt auch Schwierigkeiten haben, da äh eine neue zu finden. Auf jeden Fall scheint das Sommerloch-Thema Überwachung, Gesetz zu sein. Ich bin gespannt, ob sich das auch wirklich so lange
hält.
Ich ich fand's nur ganz nett, äh das hat man gut in den Google Alerts gesehen, zu den Nachrichtenmeldungen, zu dem Thema, dass es ihnen eigentlich überhaupt nicht gelungen ist, dieses vorzunehmen. Also in Alten den ersten Artikeln war noch irgendwie so, ja, CDU nimmt Abschied von Vorratsdatenspeicherung
Netzpolitik ORG Artikel, der gemeint hat, nein, sie
nennen es nur anders und alle anderen Nachrichtenartikel waren dann eigentlich nur noch auf dieses, die nennen das neu, die wollen das eigentlich immer noch haben. Getränkt, also,
es dir dann irgendwie nicht gelungen.
Nee, also es ist äh.
Äh nee, also auch die ganze Zeit über, über die ganzen Jahre nie gelungen, das wirklich totzukriegen, ne? Und obwohl das so ein sperriger Begriff ist, äh
scheint er doch äh noch genug Gefahr auszustrahlen so für die äh Kommunikation der Politiker, dass sie da versuchen drumherum zu marschieren, wie um so ein frisch dampfenden Scheißerhaufen, der irgendwie aufm Gehweg liegt
Ja, aber wie das eben so ist, man tritt sich dann doch immer mal wieder was ein.
Ja ja und natürlich die äh Hardcore äh Rechtsfraktion hier so Bosbach und so weiter, die meinen natürlich immer noch, das wäre ja alles total und äh Ordnung und wohl überlegt und was nicht alles und also,
wie wir ja gesehen haben, ist ja mit den Geheimdiensten alles in Ordnung. Ne, also der NSU-Skandal ist ja irgendwie immer noch prüfarm, aber es ist setzt einfach überhaupt keine äh Reflexion ein.
Reflexion setzt äh vielleicht ein auf europäischer Ebene.
Ähm was gibt's denn da Neues? Du hast auch da ein bisschen deinen Kopf reingesteckt äh rund um den Europäischen Gerichtshof, Thomas.
Ja. Ich bin jetzt schon in Urlaub auf Portugal, aber Montag, Dienstag war ich noch in Luxemburg zum Verfahren beim europäischen Gerichtshof gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
und äh damit man sich das mal irgendwie vorstellen kann, wir haben's geschafft, dass die Richtlinie zu Vorratsdatenspeicherung der Quell des Übels,
Höchstgericht geprüft wird, ob das denn überhaupt mit unseren Grundrechten konform geht oder nicht.
Wir in dem Zusammenhang.
Heißt's in dem Fall, äh also für mich der Ackervorrat Österreich, der sowie man aus Deutschland auch kennt, eben eine Verfassungsklage äh gestartet hatte, mit elftausend äh Mitklägerinnen,
die dann irgendwie von unserem Verfassungsgerichtshof zum weitergeleitet wurde. Beim EuGH waren wir aber nicht allein, da waren auch zwei andere Parteien aus Österreich, eine Einzelperson und das Land Kärnten,
und äh auch, also die hatten bei sich,
genauso Erfolg wie wir und sind mit ihrer Klage zum AGH weitergeleitet worden und der EUGH hat dann diese vier Beschwerden zusammengefasst zu einem Verfahren, in dem er jetzt einheitlich prüft sozusagen,
ist diese Richtlinie grundrechtskonform,
und am letzten Dienstag, am neunten Juli war der erste und einzige Verhandlungstag, also da wo öffentlich die Parteien äh vorm Gericht sind und sozusagen ihre Plädoyers abhalten, von den Richtern befragt werden,
und ähm da wurde eben schon sehr gut sichtbar, äh was man sich von diesem Verfahren erhoffen kann.
Im Vorfeld war schon so, dass man an den Fragen der Richter gesehen hat, dass sie das ernst meinen?
Die haben allen Verfahrensteilnehmern so fünf Fragen gestellt mit einigen Unterpunkten, die schon sehr sehr kritisch waren.
Da geht's dann einfach mal so drum, dass das Gericht wissen will wie kann Vorratsdatenspeicherung überhaupt zu Verbrechungsaufklärung dienen?
Gibt uns mal ein paar Statistiken. Ist die Aufklärungsquote gestiegen,
Also ist das wirklich ein sinnvolles äh ein sinnvolles Mittel, um schwere Kriminalität und Terrorismus aufzuklären?
Dann aber auch so im Gegenzug fragen, ja welche technischen Möglichkeiten gibt's denn da Persönlichkeitsprofile draus zu machen,
wie ganz stark auch, wie können diese Daten missbraucht werden? Wie ist die Datensicherheit bei diesen ganzen Sachen?
Da waren einige Punkte dabei wo man sich denkt ja diese Frage hätte man eigentlich zweitausendsechs stellen müssen als die Richtlinie erlassen wurde und das haben sie dann auch gefragt. So welche objektiven Kriterien hatte die EU-Kommission überhaupt zu einer Maßnahme einzuführen.
Und das war 'ne Latte an Fragen die schon sehr kritisch war und man muss wirklich sagen das war nicht ohne Popkonfaktor, weil die Befürworter der Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben sich wirklich schwer getan,
und die Richter waren auch wirklich Krätzen, wie man bei uns sagt und sind ihnen bei jeder fadenscheinigen Ausrede auf die Zegen gestiegen und haben nachgefragt.
Wer war denn die Verteidiger der äh der Sache an der Stelle? Primär.
Wir hatten wirklich einen riesigen Gerichtssaal, einen großen Gerichtssaal ähm vor Ort da. Am Europäischen Gerichtshof. Und es waren äh neben den vier Beschwerdeführern,
ähm auch acht Länder, die sich zu Wort gemeldet haben und wir EU-Institutionen,
Von den Ländern war's Irland, Österreich, Spanien, Frankreich, Italien, Portugal und Großbritannien.
Polen ist nicht gekommen und bei den EU-Institutionen äh haben sich auch alle zu Wort gemeldet, was eigentlich unüblich ist. Also das Parlament, der Rats, die Kommission und der Europäische Datenschutzbeauftrag.
Mhm. Und die Länder waren jetzt in welcher Form vertreten.
Die hatten auch äh Anwälte dort, die sozusagen gebrieft waren mit der Meinung der Regierung und diese vorgetragen haben.
Okay, also die Länder sozusagen in Form einer Vertretung der Regierungen selbst.
Genau, also es haben nur Anwälte gesprochen, bis auf den äh europäischen Datenschutzbeauftragten, da ist der äh Hackstins selber hingekommen,
ähm der auch ein ein ist nicht äh ja interessanter Mensch ist und jemand, der Datenschutz wirklich ernst nimmt und hat da eben selbst vertreten, wieso er glaubt, dass das ihn so nicht sein kann.
Und äh das heißt, wir hatten so diese acht Länder, die eigentlich alle äh natürlich pro Vorratsdatenspeicherung waren und äh Kommission, Rat und Parlament waren natürlich auch dafür.
Und vor allem die EU Institutionen wurden in die Mangel genommen. Also.
Es gab das so einige der Fragen, die sich durchzogen durch das ganze Verfahren waren, kann die EU Gesetze erlassen.
In denen diese Abwägung zwischen äh Grundrechten, ob Freiheit und Sicherheit hier in der richtigen Wage liegt, äh ob das die EU schon machen muss oder ob man das den Mitgliedsstaaten überlassen kann.
Ganz klar rausgekommen ist und das ist neu, dass äh es halt wirklich bei der EU liegt, Gesetze zu erlassen, die Grundrechtskonform sind. Und sie können sich nicht abputzen und sagen, die Mitgliedstaaten müssen das in der Umsetzung der Richtlinie richtig hinbekommen.
Also auf welches Grundrecht beziehen sie sich denn äh an der Stelle jetzt, weil da kommen ja verschiedene Grundrechte zum Einsatz, gibt ja einerseits die Grundrechte der Staaten, als auch eine.
Die europäische Grundrechte Kater.
Also für das Gericht war's äh die europäische Grundrechte Charta, weil die auch äh seit dem Vertrag von Lissabon seit zweitausendneun eben direkt arm zu wenden ist auf europäisches Recht.
Und äh da war's der Artikel sieben und acht, also das Grundrecht auf Datenschutz und Schutz der Privatsphäre.
Wir haben da noch ein paar andere dazu genommen, weil wir auch meinen, dass die Meinungsfreiheit und Versammlungsfreiheit von nur Vorratsdatenspeicherung betroffen ist, weil wenn der Staat genau weiß, wo ich mich befinde oder mit wem ich kommuniziere,
werde ich mich schwieriger tun meine Meinung zu äußern oder auf eine Demonstration zu gehen.
Aber sozusagen Artikel sieben und acht der EU. Grundrechte Charta, das war sozusagen das Fleisch der Verhandlung gegen diese zwei Grundsätze ähm hat man ständig geprüft, ob äh dieses Mittel eben,
notwendig nützlich und verhältnismäßig sind. Also das sind die drei Kriterien, die bei jedem Grundrechtseingriff gegeben sein müssen. Wenn ich sage, ich ich schränke die Freiheit ein, dann muss ich das machen, weil's wirklich notwendig ist,
einen klaren Grund dafür gibt,
Nützlich ist, weil's wirklich auch der der Sicherheit hilft und zuletzt auch äh es muss verhältnismäßig sein. Also ich kann nicht für ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit die ganze Freiheit opfern, sondern da muss es eben eine eine Abwägung geben.
Die ja dieser Kriterien, das ist so klassische Rechtstheorie, hat sich das ganze Verfahren gesponnen und dann aber auch wieder ein sehr konkreten Beispielen aufgehangen, zum Beispiel,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung sagt ja man muss diese Daten zwischen sechs und vierundzwanzig Monaten speichern.
Da hat das Gericht dann einfach gefragt, ja wie seid ihr darauf gekommen? Wieso sechs bis vierundzwanzig Monate? Und.
Warum nicht? Zehn Stunden? Mhm.
Da gab's halt keine wirklich gute Antwort von Seiten der Befürworter, vor allem der EU Kommission. Die haben dann halt gemeint, ja, wir haben doch mit Interpol geredet und die sagen schon, dass das so stimmt,
und äh dann gab's aber Studien, dass die meisten Daten, die die nützlich sind für Verbrechensaufklärung eigentlich so in den ersten drei Monaten passieren.
Steigt sinkt das ziemlich ab. Also die Nützlichkeit solcher Daten.
Dann haben sie halt gemeint, ja aber wenn der eine große Terrorismusfall kommt, dann müssen wir alles wissen.
Und auch da hat das Gericht das nicht gelten lassen. Also man ist aus diesem Verfahren rausgegangen. Ich habe da ja auch einen Liveticker gemacht für Netzpolitik org.
Und äh der Eindruck war schon sehr stark, dass dieses Richtergremium von fünfzehn Richtern es wirklich wissen will.
Die ernsthaft prüfen wollen, ob die Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit den Grundrechten konform ist und von der Show, die dort abgeliefert wurde, von den Argumenten, die ausgetauscht wurden,
kann ich mir nicht wirklich vorstellen, dass die Richtlinie unbeschadet aus diesem Verfahren geht.
Dann würde ich selber den Glauben an den Rechtsstaat verlieren, wenn wenn da nichts passiert.
Ja. Klingt ja schon mal ganz ermutigend. Ähm aber um das nochmal klar zu machen, es handelte sich jetzt hier im Prinzip um eine äh,
Anhörung. Also es kamen jetzt erstmal alle zur Sprache und du äh destilierst jetzt deine Schlussfolgerung quasi aus dem Verhalten der Richter im Rahmen dieser Anhörung. Ist jetzt noch keinerlei Ansagen gemacht worden, keine Entscheidungen gefällt worden, sondern das
jetzt überhaupt erst noch an. Gibt's denn noch weitere Anhörungstermine oder gehen die jetzt schon im Prinzip äh in die Beschlussführung?
Nein, also Anhörungen wird's keine mehr geben, das war dieser eine einzige Tag, aber äh jetzt berät das Gericht,
Und am siebten November wird der Bericht vom Generalanwalt veröffentlicht. Der ist meistens sehr ausschlaggebend für die Entscheidung des äh Richters Senats,
und wir.
Anwalt äh wer ist das? Also.
Das ist der,
in in diesem Richterkleber gibt's eben einen Generalanwalt, der ähm diesem Verfahren auch beiwohnt, der der sitzt da auch und hört zu und stellt auch Fragen und das ist sozusagen derjenige, der am Ende einen Bericht schreibt, der ziemlich,
nahe meistens bei dem Urteil ist, was am Ende auch rauskommt
Also ist der Ablauf ist der, du hast diese Anhörung, dann denkt man nach, dann äh holt man sich vielleicht nochmal Schriftstücke ein und dann schreibt dieser Generalanwalt mal,
seinen Vorschlag wie die Entscheidung sein soll und dann beraten sich nochmal die Richter und von diesen fünfzehn Richtern müssen acht eben zum selben Ergebnis kommen, dann hat man ein Urteil,
und das gilt dann, das ist dann auch sofort rechtsbindend für die gesamte Europäische Union und alle Mitgliedsstaaten und wir rechnen mit einer Entscheidung,
gut geht noch eine dieses Jahres.
Interessant. Das heißt, das könnte dem Ganzen äh Projektvorratsdatenspeicherung wirklich einen komplett neuen Spin geben, weil wenn's da eine ähnliche Entscheidung gibt, wie sie in Deutschland gefallen ist, dann ist auf jeden Fall das nicht möglich, was bisher immer angestrebt worden ist.
Und die Bandbreite, die da rauskommen kann, ist, es gibt eben so drei Szenarien grob, was da am Ende rausschauen kann. Das Schlimmste wäre natürlich, dass gar nichts passiert,
unrealistisch inzwischen. Ähm das Beste wäre, dass die ganze Richtlinie gekippt wird, also dass man einfach sagt, Verdachtsunabhängige,
Lückenlose Überwachung geht einfach nicht.
Damit, Richtlinie gibt's nicht mehr und dann kann man auch sehr leicht alle nationalen Vorratsdatenspeicherungen abschaffen.
Und der der Mittelweg, vor dem wir ein bissel Angst haben, weil der sehr Messi ist, ist halt das,
der Europäische Gerichtshof dasselbe tut, was Karlsruhe gemacht hat bei euch, der Deutsche Verfassungsgerichtshof, dass man.
Dass er so grundsätzlich sagen, so ja, äh wir stehen ihm generell nicht entgegen, aber die Rahmenbedingungen müssen andere sein.
Genau. Und ich meine, man muss schon sagen, die aktuelle Sensibilität für Überwachungsthemen ist natürlich auch ein bissel zu unserem Vorteil hier,
Also wenn die Richter jemals diese Grundrechte wertgeschätzt haben, dann ist es heute und so so auf einer Metaebene geht es eben auch, wie schon gesagt hat, um diese Frage, ob
Überwachungsmaßnahmen unsere Grundrechte noch überhaupt irgendeinen Wert haben. Also gibt's eine rote Linie, wo man sagt, nein,
Das wollen wir als Freie Demokratie nicht zulassen, auch wenn's der Sicherheit dient oder ist die Sicherheit, dass Maxime dem sich alles unterordnet.
Und ja, wir werden sehen, was dabei rauskommt.
Spannend, spannend. Wie lange äh lief diese ganze Anhörung.
Neun Uhr dreißig bis zu circa halb fünf,
und war auch irrsinnig intensiv, also äh mir sind die ich habe mir die Finger wund getippt, weil du hattest immer so zehn, fünfzehn Minuten Statements, der der Anwälte, der einzelnen Parteien,
ähm die alle eben in unterschiedlichen Sprachen vorgetragen haben mit simultan Übersetzung
sehr juristischen Begriffen, aber der Liveticker ist, glaube ich, sehr unterhaltsam. Da kann man auch wirklich so schön sehen, wie die wie die Richter es wissen wollen und wie die vor der es befürwortet in die Knie gehen.
Okay, das ist auf äh Netzpolitik Punkt äh org zu finden, der TK.
Hinaus. Verlinken wir,
nur ein ganz kurzer Nachlang noch, äh was was auch, äh um sozusagen den Bogen zu spannen, wieder zurück zu zu. Ähm es war auch der Fall, dass ähm ähm die Richter wissen wollten, einerseits,
Anonymisierungs-Tools waren so ein bissel ein Thema, das hat man immer wieder gemerkt, aber auch dass outsourcen von Vorratsdaten, also dass so es gab eine Zahl, dass sechsunddreißig Prozent der Vorratsdaten in Europa äh gar nicht auf europäischem Boden gespeichert werden, sondern,
Drittländern und vor allem eben in den USA
Wollte der Richter halt wissen, ob das nach dem, was man jetzt weiß, überhaupt noch irgendwie vertretbar ist, wenn die Vorratsdaten europäischer Bürger in den USA liegen, wo wir jetzt doch wissen, was die mit äh Datenzugriff tun.
Und äh darauf hatte die Kommission im Verfahren keine Antwort. Also der ist da auch wirklich in die Knie gegangen und hat gesagt, so äh kann ich die Frage später beantworten.
Jetzt nicht.
Kam jetzt diese Zahl her. Das ist äh das Vorratsdaten im Ausland gespeichert werden. Das ist mir jetzt auch neu.
Das war mir auch neu, aber das kam von dem Richter äh Thomas Danwitz, das war auch derjenige, der am am Kritischsten gefragt hat, der hat diese Zahl aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt während dem Verfahren. Quelle habe ich da auch noch keiner gesehen.
Wäre ja mal ganz interessant, da die Quelle rauszubekommen, weil äh das das ist natürlich das.
Das schlägt ja dem Fass äh den Boden aus, also sozusagen, ja, hier lokale Sicherheit und so weiter, klar, aber wenn wir jetzt sozusagen unsere
Voll Überwachung auch noch outsourcen und damit quasi auch noch allen anderen zur Verfügung stellen. Also,
das ist ja ungefähr so, als ob die NSA jetzt irgendwie den Cloudspeicher der Telekom benutzt.
Oder umgekehrt. Ähm.
Umgekehrt ist es wahrscheinlich dann eben so.
Ist billiger. Ähm also was da im Hintergrund steht ist äh halt
Ich glaube doch, überhaupt hier eh schon mal gesprochen. Eben das ist ein Abkommen, das sagt, dass äh die USA ein sicherer Hafen sind für die Daten europäischer
also sensible, europäische Daten, die dem Europäischen Datenschutzgesetz unterliegen,
auch in den USA gespeichert werden, weil wir da ein bilaterales Abkommen haben, das sagt ja, USA ist sicher, Stempeldorf.
Und das scheint jetzt auch irgendwie mal zumindestens wackeln zu kommen. Äh die Initiative für Netzfreiheit aus Österreich hat da mal nachgebohrt für Österreich äh wie das denn sein kann,
und äh das das ist auf jeden Fall was, das man machen kann national jetzt nachzufragen, wo liegen diese Daten eigentlich? Weil die Datensicherheit ist sozusagen einer Vektor, über die wir die VDS auch nochmal angreifen können,
weil das einfach nochmal im Vektor ist, wo man sehr gut argumentieren kann und auch sehr technisch argumentieren kann, dass das, was in dem Gesetz steht, auch so nicht haltbar ist in der Praxis.
Ja, diese ganzen äh Aufdeckungen von Snowden, die werden noch eine Menge Auswirkungen haben. Ich denke, auch in der Debatte um,
einerseits die neue Datenschutzverordnung, da hat es ja glaube ich auch schon Auswirkungen gegeben, das muss man ja bei irgendeiner anderen Sendung nochmal hinterfragen, inwiefern das im,
politischen Prozess jetzt auch spürbar ist, aber ich habe schon gehört, dass so äh nicht mehr so ohne weiteres ähm,
alle finsteren äh Forderungen, insbesondere amerikanischer Unternehmen, jetzt so unkritisch äh übernommen werden. Ähm aber auch bei der Flugart äh Fluggastdaten äh Austausch äh Geschichte, wie war nochmal kurz der.
PNR äh.
Genau, ähm ja, also auch da spielt das ja im Prinzip genauso äh eine Rolle. Und wenn die USA halt quasi ihren Safehaberstatus äh verlieren, natürlich dann eben auch alle anderen
Debatten auch taffer et cetera davon äh betroffen. Also insofern ist das auch für die USA in gewisser Hinsicht schon so ein bisschen ein Gau,
Nur wie weit das trägt, das ist offen.
Genau.
Ja Thomas, Thomas dann.
Ein allerletztes Thema noch.
Und zwar, das kam gestern raus, Netzneutralität tut sich was auf europäischer Ebene,
das wurde ja schon angekündigt und befürchtet, dass unsere allseits geliebte EU Nele Cruise äh sich nochmal zu Wort meldet, bevor sie in die,
verschwindet.
Sie hat jetzt einen Vorschlag äh zu Netzneutralität, also generell zur Telekommunikationsregulierung vorgelegt, der eben auch äh Netzneutralität,
ja eigentlich in dem es das abschafft.
Ähm ja, was was steht da drinnen? Äh ist auf äh Edri und Netzpolitik org nachzulesen verlinken wir auch, aber grob,
man da drin eben, dass genau die größte Befürchtung und Gefahr der Netzzentralität äh dort sogar explizit äh gefordert wird, nämlich dass Provider und Diensteanbieter,
eben ihre gemeinsamen Verträge abschließen können, um so eine Überholspur im Internet einzuführen. Also konkre.
Also bundling zu erlauben von Diensten.
Genau, Spotify, genau solche Sachen, findet man dort im Artikel zwanzig, explizit erlaubt,
Und damit würden sogar so Gesetze zum Schutz der Netzzentralität wie in den Niederlanden oder in Slowenien illegal werden. Die müssten dann abgeschafft.
Die das explizit verbieten.
Ja, die sammeln halt alles im gleichen Internet. Und diese Gleichheit wird wieder abgeschafft, indem ich sage, ja aber Ice Bison und Diensteanbieter können,
gemeinsam Produkte auf dem Markt bringen und da kann Geld fließen und dann werden Inhalte anders behandelt, genau das ist der Kern dieser Sache.
Ja, dann sind sie gleicher. Das ist aber jetzt erstmal nur ein Vorschlag von Neli Kröß, einen Vorschlag zu einer EU-Richtlinie oder wie?
Genau. Also das Ganze ist gelikt, ist nicht offiziell, aber purzelte eben gestern, bei einigen Leuten in die Inbox und der Zeitplan ist der, dass das jetzt bis zum Ende der Ende des Sommers wahrscheinlich in der finalen Version vorliegt,
und da müsste man das noch äh bis zu Ostern durchs Parlament bringen und absignen lassen, äh weil die Europäische Legislaturperiode ja dann endet.
Da gibt's auf jeden Fall nochmal eine riesige Gefahr, dass die die ganze Netzneutralitätsdebatte äh sozusagen mit einem Schlag äh mit einem riesigen Fail beantwortet wird, wenn die EU da durchkommt.
Und deswegen gilt es auf jeden Fall zu verhindern. Ich meine, schauen wir mal, was Ende Sommer da ist an an äh Vorschlag, aber das sieht auf jeden Fall nicht gut aus.
Noch andere äh beunruhigende äh Sachen in diesen Vorschlag jetzt äh jenseits des Bannlinks.
Ja, es gibt noch so gleich im nächsten Artikel einundzwanzig,
sogar was ganz Gutes, aber das das das könnte für dich interessant sein. Das sagte mich, dass äh wenn Provider Internetprodukte auf dem Markt bringen
dürfen die nicht nur oder oder müssen die nicht nur diese
Maximalbandbreite angeben, die ich damit erzielen kann, sondern eben auch so ein Minimum, Maximum, Avage und Peak-Angaben,
Das heißt, dass man zumindest für Bandbreiten äh realitätsnahere Angaben bekommt vom Provider und nicht mehr dieses ähm,
Bis zu wünsch dir was.
Der.
Das äh wäre in der Tat äh wobei die Frage ist natürlich, wie können solche Zahlen äh gewonnen werden und im Prinzip müsste man ja hier eigentlich eine eine Überwachung von.
Also so stichprobenartige Überwachung von einem unabhängigen Institut haben.
Ja, die die wollen halt wieder, dass dass die Regulierungsbehörden machen. Das ist natürlich immer ein bissel zweifelhaft, wie genau die das nehmen, weil die sind ja oft sehr nah dran an der Industrie
aber ähm es gibt auch was ganz Lustiges, wo man scheinbar auf ähm auf uns gehört hat. Also wir haben das zumindest letztes Jahr schon gefordert, dass man das Provider auch äh diese Daten in der Form von Open Data öffentlich machen müssen,
Das heißt, dass ich irgendwie recht gut sehen kann, äh was zumindest die Gruppenbedingungen der Internetverträge sind und das sind Maschinen lesbarer Formen,
eben realitätsnahe Echtzeit-Daten aus dem Netz.
Das ist noch vage formuliert und man weiß nicht, ob das hält, aber das das könnte sozusagen einen Schritt näher in Richtung ähm
Wettermonitor fürs Internet gehen, dass ich wirklich sehe, wie ist die Netzsituation denn jetzt gerade in diesem Segment.
Genau lohnt es sich jetzt einen Live-Podcast aufzunehmen oder.
Haben wir da äh störende Datenvolten, die aus den USA hereinregnen und uns alles verstopfen?
Endlich ein Grund, sich mehr übers Wetter zu unterhalten.
Das genau. Das Datenwetter, genau. Wenn man dazu noch die Stiftung Datentest äh äh gründen, die dann sozusagen die Bandbreiten äh versprechen, dann auch äh real überprüft dann.
Es ist sozusagen nicht nicht alles schlecht jetzt in dieser Regelung, aber es sind auf jeden Fall paar äh fragwürdige äh äh Sachen drin. Ist da dieser ganze Copyright äh in irgendeiner Form auch schon erwähnt oder ist das erstmal außen vor?
Ja, da gibt's eine ganz äh kleine Erwähnung, dass ähm Provider zumindest mal so Ingement-Infos ihren Kunden zuspielen müssen. Das heißt, die Provider müssen zu ihren Kunden eben äh,
das ist sehr unklar formuliert, aber ich ich lese es so, dass die Provider halt do do spielen müssen. Böser Kunde äh mache ja kein Fall Sharing,
Also das so die klassischen Rechtsverletzungen im Internet, die es so gibt in einem Land
ähm per Informationspflicht vom Provider an seine Kunden weitergeleitet werden müssen
Wie genau, das wird man wahrscheinlich dann erst im im Letztentwurf und in den Umsetzungen der Richtlinie sehen. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall so ein ein kleiner Schritt in Richtung Provider Haftung, wenn die Provider ihre Kunden informieren müssen, dann ist es nicht mehr hin, bis sie
dafür haftbar sind, was diese Kunden dann tun in ihrem Netz. Ähm das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein ein kritischer Aspekt, der da drinnen schlummert.
Also mal wieder eine neue Baustelle, wo man drauf achten muss, dass jetzt nicht hier wieder durch irgendeine Hintertür etwas durchgesetzt wird, was man eigentlich nicht haben möchte.
Ja. Gut. Aber ich glaube, wir haben's.
Thomas, dann äh vielen Dank, dass du nochmal deinen angehenden äh Urlaub so spontan unterbrochen hast, um hier die frische Ware abzuliefern,
wo auch ja, das ist das ist gut, geht immer an Strand, äh ich äh gehe mal hier in die Veröffentlichung
Linus äh musste er leider schon äh gehen. Der hatte dringende wichtige Termine und es war leider nicht äh möglich hier mehr Zeit freizuräumen, aber so oder so eine neue Ausgabe von
Politik ist in der Dose. Und ja, dann vielen Dank nochmal und äh tschüss äh bis bald bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.